and I think industrialization is
possible in Africa but it has to be
different from the industrialization
that has been done in other parts of the
world we are late comers into this
business and therefore we cannot just
imitate the import substitution model of
Latin America we cannot imitate the
export driven industrialization of
Southeast Asia we'll have to do it
differently and I normally advocate for
three entry points that will make
industrialization in Africa different
the first is that we have to really
focus on the parameters that give us an
edge in terms of entering the markets
the global markets and that is Natural
Resources that we possess our
commodities that we export raw we have
to get into the global value chains and
increase the value addition of our
products and in a number of these
products we have a controlling stake in
world trade so we have to use our
bargaining position much better second
we can do a green industrialization we
can leapfrog the technologies we don't
need to marry ourselves to any
technological platform that is already
outmoded and old-fashioned we actually
have the benefit of benefit of the
economies of scale that have been
produced through technological
revolutions and we can get into a more
cleaner proposal for industrialization
than others could afford and third we
need to look into the African markets
because we are expanding our markets we
have already 1 billion people the
growing middle class is going to be even
bigger organization is going to create
consumer demand and we have enormous
potential with regional integration of
course as part of the equation
to produce for African markets first and
I think the combination of these three
elements these three ingredients are
going to produce a different type of
industrialization one that is really
going to respond to an Africa that is
going to be very different
from what we know today in about 50
years we are going to have the largest
labor force in the world the youngest
population in the world one of the most
urbanized areas of the world so all of
these points into us being able to
construct today what we want for
tomorrow